oh we might get a major crap food please
so nervous
i can feel the mouse watching gonna be
way in the background here
all right we're gonna play this one
two and
[Music]
spider warren time that's right saw some
comments and messages about this second
he uploaded i was like all right uh yeah
we're gonna cover warren it's gonna
cover the spider warrens leaked toby
mcguire audio that's right copper that's
right too exciting that's right we got
some toby audio
anyway let's see what's going on welcome
back to the cosmic wonder where we talk
all things marvel and everything
relating to the marvel cinematic
universe today we have two really big
pieces of new information about
spider-man no way home one is a scene
involving tobey maguire tom holland and
andrew garfield that's what i like to
have photos of this scene before even a
leaked video but now we have some
dialogue to go along with it and the
dialogue is very clear so of course i'll
be breaking that down but also we have
some new information about a very
specific scene from spider-man no way
home as well some new things have come
to light about a certain scene and with
4k trailers we're able to see a little
bit more than we were before and it
looks like we could have been really
wrong about one of the members whoa
admitting to mistakes
we don't do that here
double down we'll first start off with
this new audio that we got in the scene
that is known now as the cot and 4k
scene unfortunately with this video we
did not get any audio it was just video
right you paid close attention and tried
to read andrew garfield's lips it did
look like he was saying something like
so you have like wet blood if this is
correct this is obviously him talking to
toby maguire spider-man who does not
have web shooters but produces them
organically well now we have audio that
kind of does prove that this is what
he's saying because the audio is now
coming from toby maguire now i want to
add that we are not sure if this is 100
real or if it's fake it does appear to
be real but a lot of people are trolling
right now so take this with a grain of
salt it's not 100 confirmed to be a real
leak however it does kind of seem like
it is oh my gosh
which i believe are actually from
different scenes or at least different
sentences but we have two nonetheless if
these are legitimate i unfortunately
cannot put them on here however if you
go to my twitter i quote tweeted a link
to this audio with the title real or
fake but cheap ploy to get people to
your twitter warren cheap ploy cheap
ploy all right i'm logging in to uh
twitter.com the greg albo who is
followed by twitter.com that john
humphrey going to twitter.com
cosmicwonderyt right now cheap ploy to
get promotion for your twitter real or
fake all right this is the one oh no
we might get a major crap food place
so nervous
i can feel the mouse watching gonna be
way in the background here
all right we're gonna play this one
two and
one
you say oh in my world octavius died you
both have web shooters look we're
letting only come from the background
speaker to be safe here oh there's some
questions though because you're saying
my world octavius died so maybe it's a
different auto octavius i guess i mean
you know i guess this implies that peter
swam down there to confirm the killing
and you both have web shooters the way
he's saying it it can confirm that he is
implying like no i still got my organic
web shooters losers that's what they're
going to be pointing at each other
let us know in the comments below are
you organic web shooter or are you peter
assembling himself like in traditional
comic book form either one is cool with
me that could just be an impersonation
too there's ways to like boss marquand
there's ways to fake that as well
there's ways to also grab people's
voices run it through a computer make
some type of weird simulation technology
beyond my comprehension but there's ways
to do it definitely sounds like him yeah
it's like candy a little bit now we
obviously know what this is about and
spider-man 2 doc ock died at the end and
he did have a redemption at the end
which i'm curious to see how that plays
out in spider-man no way home because he
sacrificed himself but he was
sacrificing himself to save everybody
from what he created so you know but he
had to change it
okay he did he redeemed himself so now
in spider-man no way home it looks like
that's all gone out the window now he
could be a variant but i'm still going
to assume that he's from toby maguire's
universe i really am at the point of
with this movie that so many people have
raised that question already just from
hearing that he's back like he had a
redemption arc that they would be fools
if there is the one from the toby
maguire universe right because this the
way that line
is
raises some suspicion that maybe it is a
variant but if it is the one
specifically from spider-man 2 they got
to acknowledge that redemption arc and
what went wrong they got it they have to
they have talked extensively about it
but at this point it's like everyone's
questioning it you got to acknowledge it
now the other set of audio goes with
what we believe andrew garfield was
saying in that leaked video in this one
toby mcguire says you both have web
shooters now if this
audio indeed end up to be real this
obviously would be a part of the same
conversation when he says you have what
blood yeah i believe him to be sane says
so you have like web blood if these
leaks are true this obviously means that
the three spider-man are going to have a
conversation about the obvious how great
is that two of the spider-man andrew
garfield and tom holland have web
shooters toby toby mcguire produces his
webs from his arms organically
technically these spider-men the three
of them are going to be variants of each
other and it would be very cool if they
noticed the differences that each of
them had i'm sure they will have another
scene to talk about and that scene is
from the spider-man no way home trailer
when we see tom holland get attacked by
something from behind we have a lot more
details about this scene now we
originally thought that this was the
lizard but when we look at this in 4k
i'm not so sure anymore it doesn't seem
like this person has a tail in fact this
actually kind of ah crap yeah
let's get spit with that
survive
still clear look at this but to me it
really does seem like we can't see a
tail here now some people have said it's
the hulk i definitely no
it's abomination
of what we saw in shanghai there's no
spikes
spikes around his neck or anything like
that
either so i'm definitely thinking it's
either venom or the lizard i think that
but this would line up so well because
that's the prison where doctor strange
is keeping them presumably from all the
leaks we've been seeing in that leaked
photo that came out with uh sandman and
lizard and then you had like electro and
goblin and doc hawk to the right side of
the frame that you know you know what
i'm talking about at this point you
should know so this would line up that
it would still be the lizard yeah i mean
i could absolutely see it and it looks
even more clearly like it's in some kind
of you know special dr strange prison
though
if it is venom venom does not like being
held prisoner so that could give some
credence to why venom might not like
spidey at first it could i would get
transported to a
aw crap
well my big question is spoil things
from post credits yeah there's stuff
about that post credit scene where i'm
like well then how would why would he
just be in prison all of a sudden yeah
i'll leave it at that yeah i don't see a
tail and if you saw the venom post
credit scene anything's possible now and
that's all i'll say about that be sure
to let me know what you think about this
venom could grow a tank you know what
you would like the three spider-men to
talk about when they finally get
together on screen don't forget to like
mainly just the struggles of being peter
parker and spiderman and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof sweet dicks
thanks for reporting and breaking it
down my friend mr warren thompson guys
follow him at cosmic wonder yt on
twitter thanks for being here hey let's
do a pink
david gandy i was thinking about it just
now i was like who's another person i
would love to see be a spider-man
variant and then we were looking over
our list of patronage and i was like
obviously it's gotta be day you just
sent us the most
generous camera package i could even
imagine and if that's not a peter parker
move in terms of generosity but also
interests i don't know what it is plus
you got insane martial arts skills
you've got kind of a quiet sort of
unassuming demeanor but you've also got
a really good heart you would be the
perfect guy to be under the suit holding
it down for you know the older
generation of spiderman the ones who are
like really awesome and sexy but you
know also have that really wise sage
life experience you know what i mean
david gandy
you know what i mean
will you be my uncle ben
[Music]
you